foreign
[Laughter]
you have to what you have to do is you
have to go to Hurricane tracker and
it'll have like little bars where it'll
be like I saw that the time and like
when yeah yeah I think I saw that [ __ ]
and then it vanished
because it was like a video
well okay it's like a video but there
should be a tracking map at this point
Sorry I'm sorry everybody yeah we just
kind of like it's wrong I think I think
it's it's it doesn't matter well it's
tomorrow so so I'm not really sure let's
put some in the comment section could
figure it out hopefully uh I gotta do
the show well yeah hopefully we'll be
able to do the show tomorrow right
um but we'll see because I'm not really
sure if we'll have power yes we have
generators yes we went today and got a
bunch of gasoline for the generators all
right I might be able to run the Wi-Fi
and then we have a backup [ __ ]
satellite but that will the streaming
will suck on [ __ ] yeah we won't be
able to stream on that because yeah we
do have backup satellite but that's not
going to be uh good enough to stream on
so I'll keep everybody posted you can
stream but it's like a 280. that's what
I'm saying yeah like we're gonna look
like little yeah little blurs like that
like little schmooze so but I'll keep
everybody apprised of what's going on
with the storm and if we're gonna be
able to
stream the show tomorrow night it's
actually not it was raining really bad
earlier because we went out to put gas
in the car and like fill up some uh some
gas can apocalypse and stuff like that
but yeah and we had to drive really far
because the gas stations closest to us
were sold out yeah so um yeah so we had
it like farther away but we did find a
place that had some
so we'll see how it goes I mean and it
was like storm it was well it wasn't
storming it was raining really hard then
but it's not raining right now like at
the moment
um okay so let's talk about
alligator from 1980. man I was so happy
that we watched this again because this
movie I remembered really liking this
movie when I was younger and I probably
saw it when I was 10 or 11 years old
something like that and I remember
really liking it and like really scaring
to you know being really scared of it
because I'm scared of alligators
um I had forgotten just how [ __ ] fun
this movie is this is a delightful it's
a good delightful movie it's a good
movie almost like an All-Star cast I
wouldn't say their stars but you
recognize everybody in them movie
the best thing about it is that that the
edit is really good it moves forward it
constantly
keeps you entertained it's never really
slow
it's just like a disaster monster movie
kind of like piranha or something well
it's actually the same uh guy that roped
piranha is it John sales I called it and
also the same guy he also wrote the
howling
yeah uh and he wrote The Planet of the
Cave Bear okay and uh he actually wrote
the first draft of what would eventually
become E.T like back when it was like a
scary movie I think it's called night
skies or Dark Skies or something like
that but he wrote that as well because I
was liking it as much as I liked piranha
yeah so it's similar but yes it's the
same writer and it's kind of like well
the thing about it I think much like
piranha because yeah you could say you
could argue these are kind of like Jaws
rip-offs they're structured very
similarly to Jaws but piranha an
alligator I think are the best of the
Jaws rip-offs are like the killer water
animal yeah uh kind of thing because
because they didn't take themselves too
seriously like there's they're funny and
they're satirical but not like goofy or
wacky and they did actually take it
seriously enough to like do good special
effects and [ __ ] like that in it yeah
and the characters were
at least kind of engage it yeah I mean
the central guy in this is a cop all
right he's an investigator and he lost
his partner before it's kind of a tired
Trope he's got a kind of a bad
reputation nobody wants to work with him
but he's got a young guy that does want
to work with him and they're trying to
figure out what the hell happened to the
dam out you know why are there all these
dead
body parts and people [ __ ] coming out
of the damn sewers and the dead dogs
showing up and missing dogs and the good
thing about it is that
the characters are not dumb they quickly
figure out [ __ ] out they're not in a bad
movie the characters never figure out
what's happening and the audience knows
what's going on and but then you're like
come on come on
he's real good he figures out real
quickly what was going on and what was
going on with the [ __ ] pets and
everything at the dam and the and the
drug the drug industry that was buying
bootleg pants from the damn pet store
and using them as
tests subjects and they get into human
growth hormones and steroids and [ __ ]
like that and it's good
yeah dogs got too big and then the
alligator got too big that's what
happens I have to say too this is also
not only was it the same writer as
piranha and the howling which are both
amazing movies but this was the same
director as cat's eye okay Cujo okay and
Jewel of the Nile okay
so movie's got a pedigree that's what I
mean and all of the actors I think I
recognized every single [ __ ] actor in
this even if I couldn't like place where
else I'd seen them yeah I mean Robert
Forster he's like the main guy like the
main cop he just really like elevated
this movie I feel like he was just such
a great character yeah even the black
cop the one that just had like a couple
of lines the character you know his
mother was reading the papers yeah yeah
I recognized the guy and he looks like
everybody he's from I don't know if he's
from T1 or he no he wasn't from
Terminator one he's from on other movies
when you see him you recognize him but
he played bit parts and cops he was
[ __ ] known for playing cops
uh yeah that's there's kind of there's
certain kind of actors that already it's
definitely yeah I feel like yeah he was
one of those but everybody including
like people that only had like one or
two lines in the movie you recognize
them
you regularly everybody was was a
character actor yeah there's like a guy
from Godfather 2 in this Robert Forster
was in you probably recognizing him in a
black hole uh he was also in Jackie
Brown that's right he was a dude from
black hole that's right because that's
what I thought yeah Jenny who is that
guy I figured you he's he was in
Mulholland Drive too yeah he was
basically the star of the black hole he
was the one that was like the captain of
the what was it the Pegasus isn't that
the name of the damn now what was the
name of the damn ship that came and
found a [ __ ] Max bomb [ __ ] man why
are you asking me these questions I
don't know I didn't I didn't ask him
questions nobody asked you know my
memory is [ __ ] up but when they uh
nobody asked you yeah I don't know but
uh yeah that's what it is that was the
dude from a black hole yeah which is a
forgotten Disney science fiction movie
that if you haven't seen it see it see
it it's pretty good it's like a classic
horror movie kind of but G-rated
it's nice yeah manga said uh Robert
Forster played a big part in Breaking
Bad that's right uh Daniel Rowling said
max Cherry yeah that was the name of his
character in uh Jackie Brown that was
Max Cherry Chef is called The Icarus it
says Icarus Oscar okay the one his ship
yeah and the other one was called the
one that went into the black hole was
called the uh
damn what was the name of that one the
cygnus no I don't know I don't remember
it I don't know is it you know I don't
have notes for that you just yeah you
pull out all these other like movies
but I saw what I saw in the theater when
I was a kid I loved it and there was
never a dab sequel
yeah yeah but then okay so the thing
about this one so obviously here's the
weird thing I'm pretty sure that I mean
they shot it in LA okay obviously
but it was supposed to be every single
thing that I've seen about this movie
that wasn't the actual movie like all
the Press stuff and the description says
it's supposed to be set in Chicago even
though it's clearly set in Missouri yeah
because there's even
there's even a thing like at the
beginning like where the little girl who
has the pet alligator who grows up to be
the um you know the herpetologist or the
the reptile scientist later on
she's coming back from vacation with her
family in Florida and it says welcome to
Missouri and then they even talk about
Robert Forster's character where he was
a cop in St Louis and then he came to
this town and I was like well this is
obviously not Louis but it seems like
it's still Missouri so I don't know why
they were trying to like make believe it
was Chicago because it's clearly
Missouri even though it was shot in L.A
it was not called the The Icarus they
were it was I was right it was one of
them was called the cygnus and that was
called the Palomino
Forester played the captain of the
Palomino that's right yeah y'all
remember y'all are good with movies
okay Danny Rowling said the guy that
plays the hunter that was uh Silva right
Henry Silva Henry Silva in this movie uh
just recently passed away yeah that's
right he played a mob boss in the film
Ghost Dog way the samurai I it's every
time I see Henry Silva I know he was in
great movies too but every time I see
him I always remember
um him from like uh was that movie that
was on Mystery Science Theater leave the
Bronx
Brock's 2000 or Escape 2000 whatever the
[ __ ] it's called it has like a bunch of
it's like an Italian yeah yeah rip-off
you know what I'm talking about escape
from the Bronx yeah or something like
it's yeah it's called I think I think on
MST it was called Escape 2000 but I
think it's usually called like escape
the Bronx or something his [ __ ] it
was it was but I mean the MST episode
was delightful uh but I remember Henry
Silva was in that like is the main bad
guy I like in this one it's funny
because he only shows up probably about
like halfway through the movie one of
the best scenes in this is when he's
talking to it's a reporter that he's
talking to right because he's supposed
to be like the great white Hunter guy
and like he comes like with the [ __ ]
Safari outfit on it he's hunted every
animal blah blah so he's gonna like come
in on this like 36-bit alligator in the
sewers and he's talking to I think he's
like talking to a reporter and he's all
like trying to you know uh trying to
like [ __ ] flirt or whatever like in
this really weird way and he's making
the alligator mating sound yeah like
after and you can tell that he's like
kind of trying not to laugh and it's
just like so [ __ ] great it's like so
it's so cringy but it's like still
really really funny
but yeah so this takes the whole Trope
about uh you know little baby alligators
getting flushed down the toilet like I
said I
can Legend I have to check on this
but there was
apparently uh a real incident that took
place in the 1930s in New York where a
bunch of little kids were like um
shoveling snow or something and they
threw were throwing snow down a manhole
and a six foot alligator kind of crawled
up and tried to get out of the manhole
and they uh they were like [ __ ] that
alligator and they caught the alligator
and then beat it to death like with a
shovel or something like that so it was
in like some of the papers at the time
so that might have been where the urban
legend came from
like that alligator nobody knew like how
the alligator got there or how it
survived or whatever they think it maybe
just like escaped from somewhere because
it does I don't think I mean alligators
can
they can survive in the cold but they
don't move around they just kind of like
they go into like stasis when it's cold
outside like a lot of reptiles do so I
don't really know like how long it would
have survived down there not at all yeah
that's the thing so so maybe it just
came from somewhere else and it happened
it was trying to get out because it was
like [ __ ] it's cold down here maybe I
don't know uh yeah they have to be able
to Sun themselves during the day so a
Subterranean life they would they would
die so they can move well if you flushed
it down a toilet and it got in a sewer
system it would spend all its time
trying to go down river or go Downstream
somehow and escape and get out they
might get might be able to get out
because that eventually leads to the Sea
yeah and they're okay in the sea
but if it was trapped in there
I don't think any I don't think any
alligator longer than 18 inches to get
enough food
it would grow and then not be able to
meet its caloric and that would be too
cold no no no no no but I'm just saying
it's a fun urban legend uh and you know
like I said it went around I remember
hearing it when I was a kid too that
it's like you know you buy the little
baby alligators and then you you know
they'd get too big you flush them down
the toilet and then they would grow to
like enormous size down there I kind of
like that they had like you said in this
one
they gave the reason for the alligator
getting so big they say it's 36 feet
right because he said it's like as big
as a car
um or actually bigger than a car like
with the tail so uh yeah so it's down
there eating there's this you know
nefarious uh pharmaceutical company
that's experimenting with these
synthetic hormones and they're of course
like because they're evil are
experimenting on little puppies
uh little doggies which is awful and
then like when the little doggies die
they're like hey look go dump them in
the sewer so the alligator's been eating
them so he's been like ingesting all
these hormones so he got like super
super big and then like nobody really
gives a [ __ ] about that but then I guess
the alligator starts eating like the
sewer workers and then like arms and
legs and [ __ ] like that like start
turning up in them yeah in the [ __ ]
popping up in the river and all that
kind of yeah there's a misconception
here you know that if you take some
steroids or growth hormones that you get
big
no there there has to be caloric intake
somewhere where's that mass coming from
yeah so yeah you could take all you
could eat
you could you could take steroids or
growth hormones out of these damn
animals that he's eating
but then you'd have to eat a bunch of
biomass to get to to grow you know and
there there isn't enough down there for
for some 36 a 36 foot log alligator [ __ ]
no no because it's an inefficient system
very inefficient protein and synthesis
so he'd probably have to eat
half his body weighted day maybe maybe
one third is body weight then there's
just no no
for the growth spurt no
it's just a movie but it's kind of funny
that they tried to pass that off there's
not a food well and you have to think
too that
um the timeline of the movie because it
turns out spoiler alert that um the
alligator like the big 36 uh foot
alligator is the same one that the
little girl's dad named Ramon I love
that Ramon the alligator I was like yeah
he kind of looks like a Ramone that was
the same one that got flushed on the
toilet and it was so it was 12 years so
she'd been down there 12 years so he'd
been down there 12 years so it took that
long to it's a movie time yeah yeah
it's a movie time no I'm just you know
you're taking it very very seriously
it's just a movie just lack of sunlight
well that's why some version of
alligator in the sewers urban legend
adds the extra detail that they're
albinos yeah you know what I mean
because because of that they're trying
to I mean there are albino alligators
I've seen them like they have them at
the alligator farm they're actually
really pretty they look like they're
made of like white chocolate if you live
down here you know more about these kind
of things and us laying out and basking
in the sun is a big part of alligators
and crocodiles life's life you know I
mean they have to have that every day
just no but it's a [ __ ] it's a cool
movie
it's a cool movie Mega says now that's a
t-shirt it's a movie Tom yeah
I just he's taking it very very
seriously I'm like it's just a fun movie
like I said piranhas don't eat people
either but it's a really entertaining
movie and the thing about it is that
um I kind of feel like when we were
talking about chud I was I was watching
a review of alligator and somebody said
I really would have liked to have seen
like an alligator chud crossover like
with the chuds like riding on these big
alligators I'm like I've been pretty
epic I'm just somebody needs to make
that but I think the cool what's cool
about this one I like chud a lot too but
this one
this one does not seem slow to me at all
this is not I mean it really it's paced
very very quickly it's basically like
you see like the baby alligator at the
very beginning and it just starts
jumping ahead jumping ahead jumping
ahead it's like that it doesn't have any
fat on it it has like a couple of little
like romance scenes you know where
Robert Forster's character is kind of
like him in the uh lady scientist are
falling in love but I don't even mind
those just because the dialogue is so
funny and you know like Robert Forster I
heard because you know there's like a
running gag in the film about his
hairline like like people keep like the
[ __ ] like picking on him about it you
know you should go to a salon for that
they could cover that up you know what I
mean like all that kind of stuff uh
apparently that started out as Robert
Forster ad libbing and like making jokes
about his receding hairline and John
sales thought they were so funny that he
decided to make that a running gag in
the film so I kind of like I don't know
I really like this sense of humor of
this as I said said it's not like over
the top and zany and wacky like I
wouldn't call it a horror comedy
necessarily but it does have like really
good comedic kind of touches in it that
really
I don't know it kind of really gets you
invested and it also I gotta say yes you
can tell that the alligator okay so how
they did the alligator they built like a
you know an animatronic sort of
alligator for some of the more close-up
scenes like the head and everything like
that and then for kind of the long shots
where you see the alligator walking
around they just have like a regular
size alligator walking through miniature
sets it's effective and I think you can
tell it's fake but I think it looks
really really good for like as low
budget as this is it's not if you're if
you're looking for accuracy and [ __ ]
with this move if you're looking for
[ __ ] realism you should be watching
this but come on you know if you watch a
movie called an alligator
we know what kind of movie you're
wanting to see anyway and you know what
I mean it's one of these
come on and this is like I said this is
one of the best nature run amok like you
know nature monster kind of movies that
came out in the wake of Jaws and in a
lot of ways it's kind of
structured a lot like Jaws because it
kind of has you know you kind of have
your sheriff or your cop character you
know like the broody
uh stand in in Robert Forster's
character yeah and nobody believes him
at first nobody because he sees it right
and his partner gets eh in like what is
pretty but that's a pretty horrible
scene like his little I can't remember
where I've seen that guy too like the
blonde guy that played like his young
rookie partner Kelly the guy's name was
yeah the one that got eaten like he got
pulled down and like pulled out and then
I was like well that's horrifying but
I've seen him before too but I can't
remember where and uh and I forgot to
look it up but so so that like stuff
happens but then like you also have
um you have like the hunter character
which would be like the Quint you know
sort of character yeah
well no no but I'm just saying that's
kind of just how to do it and then you
have like a shitty mayor that's also
kind of like on the take from the
pharmaceutical company so he's trying to
like keep all this stuff covered up but
yeah you don't actually find out they
don't actually believe Robert Forster
about the alligator because he sees him
and how big he is even like the science
lady scientist is is kind of like
pulling a Tom and being like no they
don't get that big in the thing and it's
not and then you know but then like
um that real [ __ ] uh reporter goes
down there like taking pictures and he
gets eaten by the alligator but in the
course of getting eaten by the alligator
he gets like a bunch of pictures of like
the inside of its mouth and all this
other kind of [ __ ] like all these big
kind of teeth and all this other stuff
so they're like oh I guess you were
right there is like a big giant elephant
since you mentioned Quint
thinking about Jaws again because of
what we watched it again
that character made that movie
Quinn yeah if that character didn't
exist or it was somebody else I don't
think that movie would have been
remembered the same way that quaint
character was [ __ ] and I never saw
that dude in any other movies what
happened to him did he die after that or
something or was he so Typecast they
couldn't use him in anything else I
don't know I think he'd been in a lot of
stuff previous to that
so that might have been his Farewell or
something maybe I think he was kind of a
bad drunk was he okay I think if I
remember if I you know I don't want to
like be impuning he was [ __ ] perfect
for that role man you buy that character
yeah big time yeah
fourth star down said Tom Cruise would
have gotten a real giant alligator yeah
yeah yeah
Tom Cruise had been [ __ ] funny man
he'd been talking to the Scientologist
come on we can get a giant alligator
so I told you man we can do it we'll
just make some growth hormone yeah
we can do it thank you they can use
their OT powers to make a giant
alligator [ __ ] science they'll just
look at a regular sized alligator really
hard yeah
that's a good idea
[ __ ] right man
yeah
and all roles would be folded into Tom
Cruise's role he would be the Tom Cruise
should also play the giant alligator
yeah
he's all of them yeah yeah I'd pay to
watch that movie and I don't even really
like Tom Cruise that much but I would
pay to watch that especially if he's
playing the giant alligator I haven't
seen I haven't seen the new Top Gun man
but evidently that shit's still in the
[ __ ] movie theater yeah
but uh yeah we can make fun of [ __ ]
Tom Cruise all you want I like a lot of
his movies I like Tom I think he's a
[ __ ] trip I don't agree with
everything but I still think he's a trip
yeah I think he's probably a dick you
know but I like it and then uh but you
you cannot [ __ ] say that Tom Cruise
does not [ __ ] bring it okay he brings
it all his that last movie [ __ ]
kicked ass it made a lot of money so
that's that's his job you know
so
it's not like you're dealing with
[ __ ] Steven Seagal you know
who can't really bring it
mango says Robert Shaw the guy that
played uh Quint amazing actor and writer
he also played the villain in the sting
and From Russia with Love so there you
go I thought he written a bunch of stuff
like before that they said he was a
classically trained actor holy parachute
yeah he was a bad alcoholic I remember
the stink and I remember that yeah I saw
that one remember the sting and I was a
kid when I saw it I think I saw it on
television and it was a lot of it was
above above my head over my head I
really couldn't they were a bunch of con
men if I remember correctly back in the
Roaring 20s or Great Depression or
something I'd probably like it yeah you
probably would right
Athena says hi to all I love alligator
movies big fear of mine alligators yeah
mine too and honestly this one you get
pretty much exactly what you pay for
with this one because you get to see the
alligator Munch like a whole bunch of
people like in full glorious color
because like I said the fake alligator
head that they use is great like you
actually get to see people like going in
its mouth and him like chewing them all
up it eats a kid oh my God I love that
scene so much like the scene there have
you know they're having like a little
kids party or something like that and
there's two kids dressed like pirates
for some reason and uh there's they have
another kid they're gonna make the kid
walk the plank even though that kid's
not you know he's not participating in
the pirate cosplay but whatever he was a
cowboy right yeah he's like I'm a cowboy
what am I doing here this is I'm not on
a pirate ship but yeah so they take him
out to the pool
and unbeknownst to them because it's
night time the alligator is like oh look
a little snack like coming at it he eats
the kid yeah
and then this is his brothers that threw
him in went around mob they went round
back to go [ __ ] call Mom that's
[ __ ] funny you have one less mouth to
feed
I would have [ __ ] that would have
that would have freaked me out I think
that scared me when I was a kid because
normally normally most horror movies
even back in the 80s like there were
some that went there but a lot of
American horror movies would kind of
like pull its punches a little bit like
killing a kid but that one went all in
it was like no we're just you didn't
throw that kid in the pool and the
[ __ ] alligator ate him I see it now
it's adult I know that they're trolling
they're like you didn't think we were
gonna do that but we did it [ __ ] that
kid
alligator don't give a [ __ ] yeah it's
it's funny when you see it as an adult
but as a kid that would have scared me
yeah well I think that was one of the
things that scared me it's weird because
the scene that I remembered the most
because like I said I don't think I've
seen this since
uh probably like I probably I was 10
maybe yeah
um so I think that was last time but the
scene that stuck with me the most for
whatever reason was like when I think he
was like a cop right and the cop gets
out of the car and the alligators like
coming toward him like that and grabs
the guy's legs and starts pulling him
and he starts trying to get back in the
car and like he's hanging on to like the
car like hey a door handle and [ __ ] like
that and then it's just like rock wow
but I was just like oh that scared me so
bad and that wedding scene too like at
the end somebody said earlier it's like
that wedding scene is amazing where the
the alligator just comes and like
[ __ ] eats everybody and then he jumps
on top of that car and like squishes
that old guy that's like the head of the
pharmaceutical so it's like almost like
the alligator knew like he was going to
get revenge on the people that like made
him grow that big I guess but yeah well
he's just like I don't know there's a
lot of like a lot of people around at
the wedding he's just gonna eat them all
they're just trying to the movie's just
trying to give some payoff because
you've been watching it and you want the
[ __ ] to [ __ ] go down it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] over the top the alligator
busts into the party and eats the sexy
maid
she's like oh yeah yeah she's going
right into space right down his throat
she's in the black maid outfit with the
[ __ ] white with all the damn white
[ __ ] so good apron and [ __ ]
just chopped her [ __ ] sex yes right
right in front of everybody
mate or waitress what'd you call a
waitress maid I'm pretty sure she it was
it was a traditional maze it was a
traditional yeah yeah like a maid outfit
[Laughter]
[ __ ] funny
and all the old people [ __ ] not
knowing what to do and [ __ ] oh you know
well you know and then they had some
weird scene where this [ __ ] old dude
about 70 something bald he's got to
owned the drug industry he owned the
drug Factory yeah he was going on and on
about meat and sausages and his [ __ ]
20 year old girlfriend is coming
when he's talking about it remember that
basically going on about meat and she's
ah remember didn't you catch that I
don't remember that thing yeah I was
like wait a minute maybe you were
talking or I wasn't yeah what's going on
here he's barbecuing and he's talking oh
that's right that's right okay I forgot
about oh that's right and she's going
like she's [ __ ] crazy that's right
yeah that's right I forgot about that
yeah because I'm sitting there going
with me and then I was like oh yeah when
you said what do you said when he said
barbecue yeah yeah yeah yeah
but and and it's kind of subtle it's not
real in your face but I was going like
well am I seeing this are they really
going that way or am I imagining this
[ __ ] well no because I mean like I said
the script much like the script for
piranha which was written by the same
guy it was actually like kind of clever
and was actually kind of like satirical
so there was like a bunch of little kind
of like yeah jokes and digs and stuff
yeah they were they were digging on
[ __ ] the uh uh the rich old man
[ __ ] young girlfriend [ __ ] angle
of the situation yeah she was standing
there going yeah she was a nympho yeah
and he was like yeah he was just about
to be going on about like how you
barbecue and it's like hey you really
have to do this and that again yeah yeah
yeah okay whatever dude how juicy the
meat is
[ __ ] getting off on what he's saying
she's like yeah no one wants to hear
about your juicy meat Grandpa
that's not what it showed though I know
but I'm just telling you that that's
what it really showed I tried to reverse
that [ __ ] but no I said that's no I said
that's what I was saying I wasn't like
saying what was happening no she was a
nympho she was there for the money
but yeah well maybe that's why she was
yeah she was pretending to be into it
she's like yeah leave me all your money
right yeah that's what it was
um it's like oh what's her name the old
damn blonde [ __ ] big big old blonde
that married the billionaire and [ __ ]
took all his money he was 90 something
and she was 20 something
[ __ ] want to die to the drug overdose
later back in the 90s [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
y'all remember who I'm talking about
yeah I don't remember Jeff yard said and
yet the little dog lives I was so happy
because so many dogs get [ __ ] up in
this because like I said they're
experimenting on the dogs at the
beginning so when Robert Forster's
character goes and he's like you know
it's the damnedest thing I bought a dog
and like somebody stole it like you find
out later on that it was the pet store
owner guy that stole it who the guy from
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest and um
so you find that out so he has this
little uh he buys this little dog and
I'm like oh man there's something really
bad it's gonna happen to that little dog
but the little dog makes it and I was
just like well that's good because I was
but I kind of feel like they did that on
purpose because they're like oh you
think something really bad is gonna
happen to this dog but it doesn't he's
he lives uh I think they the last time
they show him is just like
at the end like in an apartment or
whatever Anna Nicole yeah Nicole Smith
that's right Anna Nicole Smith
you guys said Piranha 3D was funny I've
been like um is that the one isn't
wasn't there one that was piranha three
double D or something like that that was
awesome well I told you that back when
we did piranha I said we should probably
do the sequel well now see alligator had
a sequel which was called alligator 2
the mutation or something like that but
I think it just went to this had a
theatrical release but um the the sequel
went direct to video now I've heard it
wasn't very good because I don't think
anybody like reprized their roles from
the first one uh so I don't really know
like from what I don't think I ever saw
it from what I could determine from like
the other reviews they're like well it's
an okay movie if you don't
um like think of it as a sequel to this
movie like just watch it as a standalone
but I don't know if it would be worth
watching because this one is just so
good and I'm not even being like
facetious when I say that it's not even
so bad it's good it's just good this is
just like a really good just like
piranha yeah it's just like just a
really fun you get to see alligators
chomping people I was going to say the
best thing too about the wedding scene
is not only do you get to see alligators
chomping all the people like like I said
in broad daylight it's like not even
dark or anything but you also get to see
him use his tail and like whack people
all over like people are [ __ ] flying
all over the [ __ ] and like flying into
the cake and flying into the tables and
[ __ ] like that and I was like that's
fantastic I like that they kind of like
changed it up a little bit yeah and they
you know they had I guess the
trampolines or the launchers and
everything like that so they're like we
got to use that [ __ ] up I read on
Wikipedia I don't know if this is true
or not but Kane hotter you know a very
famous stunt man you know played Jason
in the later Friday the 13th movies I
heard that he was
um kind of like controlling the
alligator's head like in some of the
close-up shots I don't know if that's
true or not because he's not credited
but I've heard that so I don't know if
that's the case
but honestly I think like the close-ups
because like I said they do use real
alligators in this like they're not
giant obviously but
the close-ups like where the where the
alligators like eating people and stuff
like that I think that alligator looks
really good like the animatronic one
like for being as low budget as it is
they said they had a lot better than a
shark and Jaws come on be honest that's
what I was gonna say I think it did
shark and Jaws doesn't look real at all
but they said the problem too but they
they said they had similar problems with
their animatronic alligator as they had
with uh with jaws like they couldn't get
it to work most of the time yeah but
honestly I couldn't even I don't know I
thought it looked pretty good and like I
said the scenes where they show like the
actual alligator like you can tell that
it's Miniatures but that's okay yep like
I thought it looks pretty good
mango said shut sucked
yeah I didn't like Chad
yeah I mean I like chud but I think this
is this is way better yeah this is way
better
uh Oscar said say what you will about
her that's Anna Anna Nicole Smith
um but she gave that old coot a great
time before his ancient self shot yeah
yeah yeah it's funny man I remember when
that [ __ ] happened back in the 90s for
for those of you that don't know what
we're talking about and you can look
good just Google Anna Nicole Smith
she she appeared in the 90s out of
nowhere
Chicana was like The Cutting Edge of the
big fine movement in the anglo-american
community she was just this Texas chick
who was big she was fine though and she
was a cashier at Walmart that's where
she was [ __ ] found she was really
just
kind of just a big figure big boobs and
[ __ ] I think she was a stripper for a
little while too but I think she was
also like a cashier at Walmart and she
went from that to be going becoming a
model
and like a minor celebrity and then
marrying like a 90-something year old
billionaire and she got all his money
but then that family took it all from
her
but she died of a damn drug overdose
anyway she was taking so many damn pills
towards the end of her life
she just didn't know what to do with
money she didn't know what to do with
Fame you know just destroyed her
well that happens to a lot of people
that yeah really there was nothing wrong
with her she wasn't a bad person she was
just a simple person who
got famous too quickly and got super
rich and too much and there was just
nothing to her she was literally
some chick from Texas that worked at
Walmart you know and
you pour millions of dollars into
somebody's hands like that and fame they
usually implode you know
it's just well like I said they don't
have any experience yes they can't
protect themselves they can't they don't
know what to do with the money and
reality gets warped for them and uh
they usually go into a cocoon and die
yeah it's a shame you know
Danny Rowling said Robin Riker's tits
makes this film just a tad better than
chudd now did she actually show her tits
in this no
tight shirts though yeah but yeah she's
like a perky character yeah I kind of
like
is that supposed to be clever
don't be mean it's funny
yeah I was just saying okay yeah perky
tips that's what I'm talking about it
wasn't it really a joke I'm just saying
that you said a pretty good character I
know come on yeah you know what I mean
yeah perky
the [ __ ] the weirdest scene though I
think is that like when the romance
first starts developing between them
which I thought was kind of cute but
then there's that weird Diner scene
where she's kind of like uh kind of puts
her head on his shoulder like that and
he's just like nope not having this and
I was just like what the [ __ ] happened
to you dude he's got some issues but
yeah but then like the next scene he's
like yeah sorry I was an [ __ ] I'm
like okay what was that all about
[ __ ] you all right oh I'm [ __ ]
burning up go ahead oh God yeah I'm just
burning up he's just he's just got all
kind of problems yeah he got all kind of
problems I know
but I don't I don't know what to do with
you I don't know I'll be all right in a
minute all right so I guess we're gonna
wrap it up because you seem like you're
having um yeah issues yeah
but if you haven't seen alligator from
1980 and you really like nature run amok
movies or you really like giant
alligator movies or giant sea monster
movies or anything like that alligator
is easily one of the best ones this one
in piranha easily the best of like the
Jaws kind of kind of ripoff movies I
guess
um actually alligator is on shutter I
think the second one is on shutter too
if I'm remembering at least as of this
stream so yeah this is actually like
legitimately a really really
entertaining movie I found it very very
entertaining I was never bored I was
just like all in the whole time you guys
know me I got no patience it was super
super fun I got no super fun I got no
patience for the [ __ ] I like this one
yeah I liked it too it's like it's
really entertaining yep it gives you
like I said it gives you exactly what
you pay for yeah all the characters are
great you get the alligators all over
and he eats like a whole bunch of people
it's awesome it's about like piranha
yeah yeah like I said same writer but
yeah so tomorrow we'll see how [ __ ] goes
because if you don't know we're in
Florida and we're right in the path of
uh the hurricane so we will try to do
the show tomorrow at the regular time 6
p.m Eastern but if we don't have power
or we can't get some things to work like
I'll try to keep everybody updated as to
like what's going on and if we're still
here or if we blew away or whatever so
we'll see how it goes I'm kind of hoping
that it'll be all right we'll we'll see
hopefully this house is much better
defended than their old house 15 miles
up the road don't jinx it though we went
through that hurricane don't jinx this
it went right over us I mean it was
direct hit
yeah well the main thing over here is uh
it won't flood here
and that's the main risk flood yeah so
that we're not in any kind of flood
danger that that's most of it and this
house has been hit before
so it'll be all right yeah I hope so
like I said it's more a lot less glass
in it it's more like the the power will
be out and it'll be kind of like a pain
in the ass I think it's like those
generators we got fuel in the cars and
cans and um After the Storm passes you
go out and you put your generators up
you start piping in bring in the [ __ ]
window units and start hooking up all
your damn
extension cords
so
I'll run some air conditioners up here
and try to run the internet and then
keep the freezers and refrigerators
going and the ice makers yeah because we
got all kind of food down there
including my Frozen birthday cake yeah
which I think I'll have yeah I think
I'll have another piece of that right we
had to like freeze it because the
birthday cake is good but it's like I
got like a really really rich one so
it's not like the one that you that we
got from Publix from your birthday was
like a lot easier to eat I could eat a
whole cake you just eat a little cake
but this one you gotta kind of like yeah
keep it to like small because it's very
very rich the one that I got was a
vanilla fruit
based cake with just and it didn't have
the frosting was just whipped cream on
it so it wasn't real sweet yeah and it
had
what is it kiwis and strawberries lemons
and man you could literally eat peaches
I don't remember yeah it was delicious
you could literally eat a half a cake
that is sitting and it wouldn't be so
rich and so sweet that you couldn't do
it you could just eat it yeah but the
one I got like I said is kind of more
like caramel and pecan yeah it's good
but boy it's like eating candy yeah it's
good it's good though yeah I'll get some
of it too yeah I'm gonna get some and
like so like I said we're keeping it in
the freezer so it doesn't feel bad but
yeah so like I said I'll keep everybody
a prize tomorrow of uh what's going on
hopefully we don't have any Alligators
swimming around in our yeah on the first
floor like in crawl but uh because
that's that was a hurricane too wasn't
it that like that alligator that came in
the house all right so uh have a good
rest of your evening you guys and we
will see you guys again hopefully
tomorrow